hello freak [ __ ] night and day and
really drought what the problem with
liberals Imperial Wow this is a bios
definition is that I've always thought
progressive means that you support gay
rights you support
let me try become this game worth
that'll be outcome of games with non
Gates they want case with a non games
and on case have the same when I said
I'm doing room I want that tune this is
what was gonna say there's a lot of
overlapping magisteria when it comes to
these things where we have another great
word magisteria and I've never heard
that before I really use the areas of
interest thing right they want to have
the means the area it's not so much
better than areas of interest though so
write that down Jimmy what's going to
stir is that magic scarier house I'm
glad I'm giving you something and so
yeah basically you know liberal there's
no real argument against gay rights from
a liberal perspective because liberals
want universal rights of course if some
people get married gay should be able to
get married so let's be argument I'm
Christian get [ __ ] I'm an atheist
non-argument
right whereas the progressives they want
it because someone else has it someone
else has this therefore they want this
because the one and then my whose
definition by there's a euro so you're
defining them that's what they define
out it's seemingly the other one saying
all this I mean like affirmative action
is the error example of this okay a
liberal would never ask for affirmative
action because in the liberal worldview
people should be free to pursue their
own goals now I mean the you know
liberals are usually very anti-racist
that's not that's not a category on
which you would judge some timid sex you
know I would never turn around say right
okay well you know your CDs really cared
I mean you know you clean oh you're
doing Burt you've got some tips so again
you know that won't be ridiculous you
know what that's not a not a reason to
do that but the progressive will do that
if you're a man the progressive will say
well I'm sorry we've got you know we
want equality well and this is what we
define a quality differently as I call
it your quality of opportunity they call
it quality Malcolm because they'll turn
on and say well you know we've already
got like 70 percent men so I mean your
CD might be great but you got a dick so
we can't take it we're going to take
that unqualified woman instead because
we need to get to parity because they
want a quality Malcolm there were fifty
10 men tips and well I have a friend who
was a bigwig at a big internet company
and they had to deal with that [ __ ] all
the time where they'd have men who were
far more qualified who they were
getting pressure to push out yeah to
make room for my leak that were
specifically looking for a qualified
black woman they were like going out of
their way because they wanted to give
out the appearance of diversity exactly
but that's because they're all so scared
of criticism right so they're scared of
being attacked by the rest of act and by
race pimps and there's there are a lot
of race hemp which is like art embraced
pimping
yeah it's not mine it's they used it for
Jesse Jackson back in the day I could
get some and he's been outed as a raised
pimp
I mean they've talked to people's like
yeah famously come to organizations and
said I'm going to give you diversity
courses and you're going to pay me a
certain amount of money or we're going
to protest secular religion isn't there
leave priesthood
well it's people to like gun criticized
and they don't want it to hurt their
business and I know you get [ __ ]
especially if you're dealing with an
internet business internet-based
businesses you know like like like
Google for example Apple classically
liberal right you would say for a
progressive valent yeah so very loving
in England liberal actually means a
liberal in the United States liberal
means progressive well I hate all these
[ __ ] arms there no it's it really is
a nightmare it's taken me a long time to
really be able to hammer out the you
know the ins and outs ideologically of
it and so I can explain it quite
efficiently now
[Applause]
[Music]